[Music]
Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin bring
the heat to New York ever since
rekindling their romance a few weeks
back the Biebs and Haley have been
packing on the PDA on Saturday the duo
locked lips for a steamy makeout sesh in
Brooklyn paying no attention to the
paparazzi who were busy snapping pics
according to an eyewitness the lovebirds
enjoyed lunch at the new Dumbo house
followed by a romantic stroll through a
local garden where the passionate
makeout went down and our eyewitness
says it was Haley who initiated
[Music]
a source told ET late last month that
the 25 year old singer and 21 year old
model have been casually dating for
about a month
quote Justin and Haley have always been
into one another they dated in 2016
briefly and the feelings never really
went away
[Music]
the source adds that the two have a lot
in common and connect deeply over their
faith our source says things are
definitely heating up as beaver and
Baldwin are spending more and more time
together
[Music]
you